[MUSIC PLAYING]
SPEAKER 1: Professor Goldsmith
teaches at the Harvard Law
School.
He's the Henry Shaddock
Professor over there,
and he's also a senior fellow
at the Hoover Institution.
While I was in
Boston, I took a class
with him and Bruce Schneier.
And I then became
acquainted with his work
from the legal
perspective that is
relevant to a lot of the
things that we do here
in Security and Privacy.
So with that, I'll turn
it to Professor Goldsmith.
JACK GOLDSMITH: Thanks
for coming today.
I'm grateful to be here.
My talk is the "United States
is Losing the Digital Cold War."
I'm going to collect a
bunch of facts and arguments
that you've all heard
before and that you're
more familiar with
than I am probably,
but to suggest some larger
patterns that I think
haven't been
sufficiently appreciated
and some of the
implications for how
I think the United
States is ultimately
going to have to change--
the United States government.
I don't speak for its companies.
Maybe you can tell me
about that in the question
and answer about how the US
government will have to change
its international posture.
So the Cold War is basically,
as I'm describing it,
it's a fight over what the
networks inside countries
look like.
And the United States
has a particular vision,
which I'm going to talk
about in the second.
And at the other extremes
are the Chinese and Russians
and Irans of the world, who
have a particular vision.
And somewhere in the middle
is the European Union.
And there's a fight going on.
It's on the surface, but it's
also happening more vigorously
below the surface,
about what networks
look like both in
these countries
and in these geographies.
And these countries
and geographies
have views about how they
look in other countries.
The United States' vision,
Secretary of State Clinton
gave a speech in
January of 2010 stating
what she described as the State
Department's Open Internet
Agenda, or Internet
Freedom Agenda.
And it really-- the speech
got a lot of coverage
as something new and important.
But in fact, it represents
the United States view
about internet regulation
globally going back
to the 1990s.
These are the main tenets.
The United States is in favor
of free flow of information
across borders, generally
against censorship on networks,
generally against
blocking online services
and most types of take down--
the exceptions is largely
for intellectual property--
against burdensome
internet regulations.
The Internet Freedom
Initiative was
designed to push all
of these positions
globally and also, beyond
that, to pay for and subsidize
and to proliferate
and distribute
tools in authoritarian
states that allowed activists
to circumvent control on digital
networks in those nations.
That was an important
part of the initiative
to try to help literally bring
the technology to activists
in other countries to
help them circumvent
the control on those networks.
Clinton said in her
speech that, of course,
we can't have all
of these freedoms
without robust cybersecurity.
So that was an
important part of this.
And she said, we should try
to create international norms
to guarantee this.
Now, these are
familiar principles
because they're basically
Google's principles.
This is from a 2013 paper.
And the US government's vision
is basically Google's vision.
It's basically the
large IT industry,
global IT industry centered
mostly here's vision.
And so there's really not
much difference, as far
as I can tell, between
your vision and this vision
of the US government they've
been pushing for 20 years
and that you've been pushing,
as far as I can tell,
since you've been founded.
The vision is in tatters
is what I'm going to argue.
It's in tatters because nations
increasingly and successfully
are imposing control,
digital borders,
and imposing control on
networks within their borders.
This is nothing new.
It's been happening for a while,
even though 20 years ago, we
were told it was impossible.
But it's gotten--
I think authoritarian states
have become more and more
successful at this,
which is contrary to what
a lot of people predicted.
This digital control
abroad is having
an impact in the United States.
This is the example of
the right to be forgotten.
I'll come back to this example.
But sometimes digital
control abroad,
such as Europe's attempt
to impose a right
to be forgotten rule
on Google, if they
order Google-- there's
a big case in Europe
now to take down certain
data not just on servers
on Google in France or
in Europe, but globally.
That's what this debate's about.
Can Europe, in effect, impose
a global rule on Google?
And if they can, then
they are, in effect,
effecting internet freedom
here in the United States.
And finally, as the
election showed,
but that's only one
example, adversaries
exploit internet openness
in the United States.
And more generally--
well, let's just
say those are the three
main pieces of evidence
that this agenda's in tatters.
I'm going to talk about
this and why it's happened.
So these are the three reasons
why the agenda's a failure.
And I don't know the extent
to which you appreciate this,
especially if you're
in the United States.
But the United States talks
about internet freedom
and internet openness.
But it is, both its
government and its firms,
widely seen as the
biggest bully on the block
when it comes to malicious
activity in the networks,
starting with the
militarization of the network.
Stuxnet that is the
greatest example.
But as President Obama bragged
in his press conference,
at his last press conference
at the end of the year,
no nation has more
powerful offensive weapons,
digital weapons, than
the United States.
And it appears that no nation
is using them as robustly.
Although that's now in question
since we're on the receiving
end of a lot of it.
The Snowden revelations,
it's hard to exaggerate
how much the Snowden
revelations, which
were two years after
Clinton's speech, really
just was widely viewed as
exposing the open internet
agenda of the United
States and the sham,
since it showed that
the United States was
inside digital networks
throughout the world,
breaking into endless
numbers of systems,
extracting information, and
using it for various reasons.
And if there's one event
that increased the backlash
against this
initiative, I would say
it's the Snowden revelations.
Finally, US firms are viewed
as imperialist arms of the US
government.
I'm not sure this is
true of consumers.
But certainly in
Europe, the governments
view US firms as imposing
their particular US
vision of the internet
on their countries
in ways that affect
their culture.
It affects their norms.
It affects their
fundamental commitments.
So one big reason why
this initiative has failed
is because people don't like it.
They don't like it, and
they think the United
States is hypocritical.
The second two
reasons are what I'm
going to focus on
the rest of my talk,
that the United
States simply can't,
has been unsuccessful in
imposing openness abroad
in other countries, and
that openness at home
is increasingly not all
it's cracked up to be.
So I'm not going to go
into detail about this,
but just looking at China.
China has-- I wrote a book
with Tim Wu 10 years ago called
"Who Controls the Internet?"
And we had a chapter about China
and how China had 10 years ago
pretty successfully, despite
widespread predictions
to the contrary and despite the
fact that there was flourishing
internet activity in China,
that China had brought pretty
good control, through
various techniques,
filtering at the border,
lots of monitoring inside,
and a variety of other
techniques-- censorship
inside, monitoring
inside, enforcement
of laws inside
the-- in the country
that had a deterrent
effect on others.
China has only gotten
much, much better
at controlling its networks
in the last decades
since I wrote that book.
And these are some of the
many ways that nations
have used to, in effect,
impose the will that they
want-- and I'm talking
about authoritarian states
here-- impose their
view of what's
acceptable and not acceptable
behavior on the net.
So filtering at the wall,
China just is implementing.
It's still not clear how
successful this will be,
but it appears that it might
be successful at an internet
identity registration program
and having a social credit
system attached to that.
It can be used for all sorts
of methods of social control,
including control in the
network, surveillance,
wiretapping, censorship,
denial of information access,
or accessing information inside
the user that the state--
inside the computers
or the devices
that the state wants to control.
States have gotten good at
temporarily shutting off
the internet, taking content
down from the internet,
slowing down the
internet, shutting down
cell towers when
necessary, and interrupting
the communications they want.
They have ramped
up laws and actions
against tools designed to
circumvent these crackdown
methods.
And they're trying to
develop homegrown platforms
to replace foreign
platforms over which
they have more control.
This next bullet point
is much of the same.
They use law to go after authors
and dissidents and journalists
in a way that has a significant
deterrent effect on speech
in the country.
And there's regional
coordination about this.
The Shanghai Cooperation
Organization,
I think that's what it's called,
is an organization primarily
with China and Russia.
But India and
Pakistan just joined.
And it's an organization--
and there are other nations--
that is designed to basically
to package these norms
and promote them as part
of the global order.
It's basically
organization that's
over and against Western
Europe and the United States.
But they are coordinating and
trying to export this vision.
Now, in the Arab
Spring, many people
thought that social media--
let me just say the last note.
Encryption alters
methods of control,
and many people
thought-- and again, I'm
not going to tell
anyone in this room.
In fact, I can
learn from everyone
in this room about this.
Encryption was thought
to, and it does,
enable confidential
communications that the state
has a hard time getting at.
But there is a new report by
my colleagues in the Berkman
Center at Harvard
just this summer
that showed that encryption
presents a problem for states,
but they found techniques
to deal with it,
including this entire list,
as substitute ways of control.
Plus, encryption, at least
encrypted communications
from abroad, it makes
it, as I understand it,
impossible for the state to
filter out at the site level
but not at the platform level.
So they can keep Wikipedia out
of the country if they want,
even if they can't
block particular pages.
So what encryption does
is it forces the state
to make a choice, an
all-or-nothing choice.
Some states have
made that choice.
The point is, is that
encryption is not
the killer thing
that's going to bring
the states to their knees.
They have other methods
of imposing control
within their borders.
So the Arab Spring is
a pretty good example.
It seemed to be coordinated
by social media.
It seemed that social media is
what enabled the organization
and collaboration
of the protests
inside authoritarian-- inside
the Middle Eastern countries
and North African countries
where it took place.
There was a question at
the time about how much
this movement was
really internet enabled
and how much it
was something else.
But the key point is that
the authoritarian states
learned from that experience.
And frankly, in a
lot of cases, they're
using the network
against the dissidents.
They are attacking them back
and using the network as a way
to monitor the dissidents.
But the point is that there's
been a ton of learning
and a ton of learning
about how to control
social media in these states,
to the extent the states want
to use them.
And as Ron Deibert said,
the authoritarian regimes
have proven themselves
surprisingly and dismayingly
light-footed and adaptable at
controlling internet and social
media and using
them, through some
of the ways I said in
the previous slide,
to assert control.
So this is a
Freedom House study.
You can't, obviously, see
the countries very well.
And these are
qualitative judgments
about the extent of internet
freedom in the country
that talks about access, content
control, unlawful surveillance,
or surveillance and the like.
And the purple
countries are not free.
The yellow countries
are partially free.
The green countries are free
by these qualitative standards.
Without getting
into the details,
and, again, this is
a qualitative study,
it's not the most
rigorous study.
It is the most rigorous
study because it's
the only study of its kind.
But it's not terribly rigorous.
It's very qualitative.
But using their
qualitative standards,
they've said every
year in the last six
years that freedom has declined
and in any number of ways.
And the content
control, in particular,
is not just about
political speech.
It's about all sorts of speech--
religious speech and the like.
And the study concludes
that 2/3 of internet users
live in countries where
criticism of the government
or the military is censored.
So that is, in effect--
so I would say that in
this battle for control--
for openness versus control
in authoritarian states,
I would say that authoritarian
states are winning.
And I would love to know if
any of you disagree with that.
I think that's conventional
wisdom that they're winning.
The EU vision is much closer to
ours but importantly different.
And I don't need to tell
people at Google about this.
They have a different
conception of the government's
relationship to the individual
and the individual's
relationship to data and firms.
They have different
conceptions of privacy,
and they tend to value privacy
and their conception of privacy
and consumer protection over
free speech and free trade,
as we understand it.
They're much more inclined
to regulate than we are,
and especially after Snowden.
At the European level, which is
where the regulation goes on,
they have a heightened
suspicion of surveillance.
So, again, I don't
need to tell you
what the consequences
of this are,
because Google's
living this now.
But basically in
this space, when
Europe has a more
burdensome regime
on a company like Google
doing business there,
it's successfully
able to impose it.
And we've seen this
in all of these areas,
and Google has suffered
fines and penalties
and legal restrictions
and threats of regulation
and all of these measures,
in all of these contexts--
antitrust, hate
speech, privacy, taxes.
A lot of these
might be motivated
by protectionist concerns.
A lot of them might be
motivated by value differences.
A lot of it is probably
some mixture of the two.
The point is that Europe
has a very different vision
of what counts as
proper communications
within their borders
and what counts
as what can be done with the
data within their borders.
And the key point is, just as
the authoritarian states are
able to control
in their borders,
Europe is able to
do what it wants.
It's a giant market, to
which all the major companies
want access.
And it has successfully, so far,
imposed its different rules,
different and more burdensome
than in the United States.
It's not just-- so
the point to here
is the authoritarian
states are doing what
they want within their borders.
Let me just say I'm not
saying they're always
getting exactly what they want.
There's often an arms race,
a technological arms race,
that, again, I don't
need to tell you about,
between methods of control
and circumvention of control
or methods of freedom.
But in general, the trend
has been towards control
and towards states,
especially states
with decent market power, where
big firms want to do business.
They're able to impose their
vision on those companies
and through other
means to ensure
the types of
communication they want
to allow in their countries.
It's not perfect.
And from their perspective,
regulation never is.
But it's successful.
So I've talked thus
far about nations
being able to control content
flows in their borders.
But there is also, as part of
this larger set of conflicts
going on between
nations for control
over communications within their
borders, there's also exports.
Part of the Internet
Freedom Initiative
was for the United States to
export digital freedom tools
and anonymity tools,
censorship circumvention
tools, and the like.
US companies also
export technologies
of control, filtering
technologies
of various sorts and the like.
So we're in the business,
the United States, of both
exporting the tools of
freedom and tools of control.
The authoritarian countries,
China, in particular,
has a robust export
business in selling
what it's learned over the
last 20 years, its technologies
of control.
And it has helped Russia.
It has helped Iran.
It has helped endless
number of countries.
I'm not sure exactly what
the technologies that
are being exported are.
But there's a lot of
consultation and coordination
and sale of hardware and
software products from China
to authoritarian countries
that want to replicate its
means of control.
And finally, those are real
exports, and the last category,
these are sort of
indirect exports.
And that was talked
about just a second ago.
The right to be forgotten, if
this case in the highest court
in Europe succeeds,
and I think it's--
I believe it is Google
Spain, in Spain, that
was socked with this
order, where it started,
about giving individuals
a right to remove
certain data about them
from Google searches.
And the ultimate
order, I think it
was in the highest
court in Spain,
was that to make this
effective, the data
had to be removed not just from
Google SP or whatever it is,
but from all of
Google's networks,
from all of its databases.
You can't get access
through its searches
to this information
anywhere in the world.
So to the extent that happens,
to the extent's enforced
and to the extent Google
accepts it and continues
to do business in Europe,
as I predict it will,
that means that--
I don't know how big
an effect this is.
But if it's a big
effect in Europe,
it's going to be the same
effect in the United States,
and that information won't be
available on Google searches
in the United States.
So that's a form of
export of control.
Same thing with privacy--
the data privacy regime that
Europe's Europeans have,
which is more restrictive
than in the United States,
same impact in
terms of companies
tend to, if they want to
do business in both places
and if they want to be
able to mingle their data,
they tend to bow to the
most restrictive regime.
And so, in effect,
European privacy rules
have an impact both
on our privacy rules
here, which you might think is
a good thing, you might not.
And it also have an impact
on our surveillance rules,
because that's what
they're really angry about.
What they're really angry about
is data coming from Europe
to the United States to US firms
in a way that the United States
government can get
the information,
either through direct orders
or through some other means.
And so to the extent
that we've been
in a argument the last three or
four years with the Europeans
about whether we need to
tighten up our surveillance
practices in order to satisfy
their privacy rules, again,
it might or might
not be a good thing.
I want to stay away from
that normative question.
The only point I want to
make is that Europe has
a big extraterritorial impact.
Finally, I'll say that
this is a prediction,
but the Europeans
are, in general, ahead
of the United States in
thinking about and beginning
to legislate ways to force
companies to give them
back doors or some equivalent
to encrypted communications.
And this is a prediction.
If it starts happening,
I don't think
it's going to happen here.
I don't think there's
much of a chance of it
happening here in the
current environment.
But the dynamic will
change, I predict,
if European
countries, Australia,
and even non-Western
democracies,
nations that aren't
Western democracies,
start insisting on
this, it's going
to be harder and
harder for companies
to resist these types of
initiatives in the United
States, I predict.
So that's a form of exporting
digital control indirectly.
So I've been talking
thus far about the ways
that the Internet
Freedom Initiative is not
working in other countries.
Again, the initiative was to
bring the American conception
everywhere.
And I've been talking about
the ways in that's not working.
Now I want to briefly talk
about the ways in which--
we're just at the beginning
of this conversation,
at the beginning of
understanding it.
And again, you know more
about this than I do,
so I'd love to learn from you--
but the ways in which
openness isn't all it's
cracked up to be at home
and for two reasons.
I'm going to focus on two
reasons, cybersecurity
and speech.
So not all of these are actually
assaults on the US networks.
This is just a list
of things pulled
from the headlines of 2017 that
involves some kind of cyber
attack or data breach
or cyber exploitation
or something like that.
And the list goes on and on.
And the point is simply as--
the White House
Cybersecurity Czar Rob Joyce
was talking in
Cambridge the other day.
And he said that basically
that we've become numb to it.
It happens every day.
We're like the frog slowly
boiling in the kettle.
It's getting worse and worse
and worse and worse by the day.
And we really don't have a
plan to deal, as a nation,
with our cyber insecurities.
And so the point I want
to make is that openness
contributes to this.
It contributes to this
because-- and, again,
you all know more
about this than I do--
closed societies
are able to have,
to the extent they can
impose, get rid of anonymity.
To the extent they can control,
information flows better.
To the extent that
they can eliminate
encrypted
communications, they're
able to deal with the
cybersecurity problems better
than open societies.
Something that's not
as easily understood
is that our very openness makes
it harder for the United States
to respond to cyber attacks.
And I can give you
three examples of this.
President Obama
here was speaking
at his press conference at
the end of-- his last press
conference last year.
I think it was that on.
It may have been the one before.
It was the press
conference in which he was
talking about the Russia hack.
And he was being questioned
about why the United States did
not do more.
And he explained that-- and
this is a perpetual problem
in our deterrence strategy.
Deterrence requires--
to deter, you
have to credibly be able
to commit to impose pain
on the adversary when the
adversary does something to you
that you don't want
to happen to you.
And the problem that the
United States finds itself
in over and over
again, and this is
what Clapper is talking about,
is that every time the United
States thinks
about retaliating--
this happened with the
Iranian bank attack in 2012.
It happened with the Korean
attack, the Sony hack.
It happened most
notably in the DNC hack.
That the United States hesitated
and in some situations did.
nothing.
Why?
Because when they
gamed it out, they
thought that the retaliation
to our retaliation
would be worse for us.
And they did a
so-called escalation.
We're going to end
up being much worse.
Why?
Because our networks are
open, because we're more
digitally connected, because
we're more digitally dependent,
and we have more to lose
from that escalation.
So that's what Obama
was talking about when
he says that we're more
vulnerable partly because we
have a more open society.
There are other ways in
which we're more vulnerable.
I'll get to that in a second.
And it's why this is James
Clapper, Obama's Director
of the DNI, the Director
of National Intelligence,
and he said that--
he was explaining that we didn't
respond to the Iranian attacks
precisely because we thought
the consequences for our banks
would be worse when
Iran counter-retaliated.
And he said earlier,
and this is, I
think, the conclusion
of the US government,
we simply can't do deterrence.
We can't do defense
very well as a nation.
We can't do deterrence very
well as a nation, which is
why the frog is slowly boiling.
This is a big topic.
But the internet has
really changed speech
in this country in
such a way that--
and I'm only going
to be able to touch
on this briefly-- but in such
a way that makes openness
and the open networks
and the speech
that our social media
that is uncensored largely
makes possible, it has a
lot of pretty bad effects.
We've seen-- I don't
have to remind you--
about how social media can
be used for disinformation,
misinformation, and propaganda.
This was going on
in the election.
It's very clear now.
We've seen troll armies.
That because the
internet enables groups,
enables private individuals to
both coordinate in large groups
and attack someone in ways
that are very intimidating,
and so we see speakers
being intimidated.
We see flooding tactics
that distort or overcome
disfavored speech through fake
news, fake commentators, bots
of various sorts, and the like.
We see the splintering of news
media, such that everyone has--
not everyone.
I don't.
But many people have what Cass
Sunstein calls the "daily me."
We only get the information
that confirms your biases,
and you don't have
to confront facts
that don't confirm your biases.
This is all by way of
introducing a topic
that I think we're familiar
with, which is that there's
a lot of downsides to openness.
The free speech assumptions
behind the Open Internet
Initiative were the old
free speach assumptions
that don't really apply when
every speaker has access
to a platform and can speak,
and that speakers can coordinate
and send out successfully
harmful information
or misinformation
in a way that drowns
out what some might think
is more legitimate speech.
So I think the most ironic thing
about how the open internet--
the openness agenda has
been upended is Clinton
gave her speech in
2010, and it was
directed overtly at
authoritarian countries.
Russia, at the time,
was complaining.
China, at the time,
Part of their platform and
the Shanghai Cooperation
Organization is
that nations should
have sovereignty
over their borders,
and other nations
shouldn't meddle.
And Clinton's
speech was basically
about how we're
going to be meddling
in authoritarian networks
to help bring openness
to those networks.
And let me say that China
and Russia view that--
I'm not defending it.
I'm explaining it.
They view that
about the same way
that we view their Russian
meddling in our election.
And frankly, it
is the same thing,
except that they are
meddling in a democracy,
and we're meddling in
an authoritarian state.
And that might be-- it
is different normatively.
But from their perspective
it's exactly the same thing.
And Putin was sure, and he
said so, there were protests.
After the 2011 legislative
elections in Russia,
there were protests.
He explicitly blamed Hillary
Clinton for basically
organizing-- her State
Department for organizing and--
basically organizing and
coordinating the protests
and helping them get started
and giving money for them.
And frankly, the
United States has
a history of meddling
in Russian elections.
President Clinton's
administration
intervened in a lot of ways in
the election of Putin-- excuse
me, of Boris Yeltsin in 1995.
And his assistant, Vladimir
Putin, was watching.
The United States
has long interfered
in foreign elections, as has
the Soviet Union and Russia.
So anyway, this Open
Internet Initiative,
which was supposed to
bring freedom to Russia,
basically is what
happened to us.
We said we were going to
meddle in your networks
to bring freedom, and they
meddled in our networks.
And it turns out that
Putin won, and it turns out
that openness is on the
defense, when he basically
combined a very simple
phishing operation and taking
advantage of our open media
and uncontrolled media.
And that's all it was, and it
had a devastating impact on--
who knows if it had an
impact on the election--
but certainly in the
confidence of our institutions.
So the very-- not
the very tactics,
but close to the
very tactics we said
that we were going to use
to bring freedom to Russia,
they basically used to
us to call into question
the legitimacy of
our electoral system.
Last slide, these
are predictions.
And they are very
long-term predictions.
And I'm just starting
to think about these.
But I basically think that
what the United States,
its approach--
I'm not talking about companies.
I'm talking about
the government.
Its approach towards these
issues is unsustainable.
I imagine that
companies like Google
will muddle through and
accept the $2.1 billion fine
and what I take to be a tweak to
their advertising and move on.
I don't know what the
limit is to Europe.
Europe is just going after
big American IT firms
like crazy now.
I don't know the limit is.
I think the limiting
factor is what
the consumers in Europe, whom
I think like American products,
will put up with.
But for now, the European
Union, along the dimensions
I mentioned, sees US companies
as a big, giant target,
and they're going after them.
I imagine that the
Googles of the world
will be able to handle that.
I don't know where that will go.
But I think we'll
muddle through on that.
And when it comes to
the Chinas of the world,
it's been clear for a long
time American companies that
want to do business
in China will
have to do business in
China on China's terms.
And the US government is
not going to change that.
And I think American companies
that want to do business there,
they have been complying with
China's increasing demands
for access to
proprietary information,
for cooperation
with the government,
for cooperation with
local firms and the like.
So we'll muddle-- you,
the Googles of the world,
will muddle through with
those foreign regulations,
using the tools they can
to try to deal with them.
I think that the Internet
Freedom Agenda is certainly
dead with the Donald
Trump administration.
Nobody's talking about that.
No one seems to care about that.
But I think the very idea of the
United States bringing openness
to these countries is dead.
I don't think it's
a viable strategy,
and I don't think it
will ever be achieved.
Maybe it will be part of
our rhetorical strategy,
but I think it's dead.
This is another big topic.
But I really want to
emphasize that what
we see as these
terrible intrusions
into our electoral system
and into our networks
by the Russians hacking
into the DNC, hacking
into electoral
systems, it's widely
viewed by the rest of the
world that this is what we do.
And along different
dimensions, it is what we do.
We're in other nations' networks
in a very aggressive way.
We use military
tools aggressively.
Stuxnet is the best example.
The Snowden revelations were a
shock to the rest of the world
and to people in
this country as well.
And I think that the
United States never
has a chance of getting
relief from these type of very
aggressive intrusions by other
countries that are going on
in many dimensions--
I didn't talk about
them much-- until it's
willing to put
something on the table.
What are you going to give up?
I mean, is the United
States willing to pledge
that meddle in
Russian elections,
the way it was alleged to
have done in 2011 and the way
it did in 1995, in exchange for
Russia not doing that for us?
I'm not even sure that's
a possible deal that
could be made.
But is it even something the
United States would consider?
Would we consider pulling
back on the use of some
of our offensive cyber
exploitation and attack tools
in exchange for relief
from other countries?
I predict that we're going to
have to face that possibility,
even though no one's no
one's talking about it now.
And I think that
there's going to be--
and, again, this is
very big picture,
and I certainly don't
know the details,
but we're going to have to
rethink openness at home.
There's going to be
a lot of pressure
on the Googles of the
world, and especially social
media platforms,
to bring control
over so-called fake news.
That's a very difficult task.
And the attempt
to do so is going
to burden a lot of
legitimate speech.
And I think we're only
beginning to get on that path,
and we haven't figured
out what that looks like.
But there's going to be a
rethinking of freedom of speech
in this country due to what
the downsides of open speech
on these networks is.
So those are my predictions.
And if you have any questions,
I would love to take them.
AUDIENCE: So you made a
series of predictions.
What prescriptions
might you make?
Like, that's
something we will do.
What you think we
actually should do?
JACK GOLDSMITH: That's tough.
I tried not to say anything
in the whole talk about what
we should do because
it's just very tough.
I think that something like
each of these three things
should happen, will
have to happen,
and they probably should
happen in reaction
to the changed world.
But I really don't know.
So even if the Internet
Freedom Agenda doesn't work,
does that mean we should stop
supporting dissidents abroad
who are trying to achieve
freedom in those countries,
trying to circumvent control?
I don't think that.
But if there's a relationship
between our support for that
and this terrible
predicament we're
in with our electoral system
and with other things going on
in this country, then I think
it does need to be rethought.
The same about very aggressive
use by the National Security
Agency of its cyber tools.
If there's is a
relationship between, and I
believe there is, our very
aggressive use of those tools
abroad and what's
happening to us at home,
I think we need to rethink that,
if we can tamp down on that.
And there's definitely
going to be--
we're in the middle of
rethinking about what kind
of speech we appreciate and
how we're going to regulate it.
And I know that's
going to happen.
I don't know that
should look like, sorry.
AUDIENCE: We have a
question from Zurich.
How do you see the role of
multinational corporations?
What are the points
of collaboration
between governments
and corporations
for promoting political,
social, and economic openness?
And who should be
taking the lead?
JACK GOLDSMITH: That's
a tough question.
So I don't know how this
person is communicating.
I'll try to answer it.
And he or she may
want to follow up.
So my view about this
is pretty simple.
Each company decide for
itself what its values
are consistent with what
the law of the United States
permits it to do.
There are a lot
of companies that
are exporting tools that are
facilitating oppression abroad.
That's not illegal.
A lot of it is not illegal.
So companies have
different values.
And they have to
decide for themselves
and their shareholders
what they want to do.
Governments-- so I
will just say this.
I think I can answer
the question this way.
Governments will impose
order on corporations
within their borders to the
extent that they want to.
The only question is
whether the US government
should take a stand about the
extent to which US corporations
can be doing business,
say, in China or Iran
or something like that.
And to date, we do
have laws about that.
They're called sanctions laws.
You can't do business
in some nations.
I ultimately think--
my very simplistic view
is that corporations
should be able to do
what they want to do
consistent with their values
and whatever they're
trying to maximize,
consistent with the law,
anywhere in the world.
And if the US
government, which is
where these corporations
are, wants to change that,
then there needs to be
a law that's passed.
And that's it.
And actually, I hesitate very
much to have the US government
intervene in places like
China to tell companies what
they can and can't do there.
For a whole host of reasons
I think that's a bad idea.
AUDIENCE: So you talked about
what you think the United
States will do or should do.
But we, at this
point, don't seem
to have a good idea of what
our conception of open networks
are?
Like there's an ongoing
debate about net neutrality.
There's stuff about the NSA.
Is it possible for
us to do anything?
I mean, I guess
doing something, that
means that the Rob Joyces
and Hillary Clintons
world and Googles of the world
get together and figure things
out.
is that a possible way forward?
Or do we need an
open conversation?
And if we need an
open conversation,
how do we do that,
when in the past,
the way that things have seemed
to been done with things like--
The NSA essentially came out
of secret Bush administration
programs.
The Open Internet Agenda was
an Obama administration thing
that they just sort of wanted
to do, without a whole lot
of public discussion around it.
So how do we avoid that the next
time around, especially given
the state of
current US politics?
JACK GOLDSMITH: OK,
hold on to the mic
because I have a
question for you.
I don't really understand
what the question is.
AUDIENCE: Sure.
JACK GOLDSMITH: So I
understand everything you said.
But could you-- let
me just say one thing
and then you can tell
me about the question.
So the Open Internet
Initiative, when
I started thinking
about this, it's
actually hard to pin
down what that means.
It means a lot of
different things,
and different
people-- and I gave
a list that was basically
the general list
that I was able to
discern from her speech
and from other things.
And it's basically free
trade in digital goods.
I mean, that's basically
what it is, both domestically
and internationally.
So with that background,
could you just
give me a short version
of the question?
Because I didn't really follow
what you wanted me to answer.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, so how do we--
do so do we need an open
conversation about what
the United States should or can
do within the United States?
Do we need to agree about what
our conception of the US role
in the internet is ?
And two, how do
we do that, given
that in previous iterations of
this problem, when the United
States has taken a stance
on these sorts of things,
whether it's regarding the
NSA or sort of open internet
of things, that seemed to have
been small groups of people
in various policy communities
essentially saying,
we're going to do this, and
either doing it secretly
or doing it without
sort of public mandate.
The Obama administration
did not have open internet
as a major sort of
plank of their platform.
Obviously they talked about it.
JACK GOLDSMITH: You
mean Trump or Obama?
AUDIENCE: Obama.
JACK GOLDSMITH: OK.
AUDIENCE: President Obama,
when people say, why did you
vote for him, I'm not sure
that open internet was
the first thing on
their mind, right?
There's not sort
of a public mandate
for him to go off and start
imposing open internet
on the rest of the world.
JACK GOLDSMITH: I agree.
So let me just say
a couple of things,
and I think this will
answer your question.
The first one is, yes,
unless we as a country
have a coherent conception--
I'm talking about
the government level.
I mean, firms have
different motives,
and it's hard for the
government to coerce them
and their business abroad
for reasons I just said.
It doesn't happen that much.
But let's just talk
about the government.
The government needs to
have a coherent conception
about what it's doing and why.
I don't see actually
that much of a difference
across administrations.
The only thing Hillary Clinton
really added in that speech
to what Bill Clinton
was saying in the 1990s
was this idea that we're
going to subsidize and pay
for these--
and that might not
even have been new--
these tools to help people
circumvent control abroad.
And the NSA stuff, yes,
that started with Bush,
but it continued
right through Obama.
And so there's
actually continuity
across administrations.
I don't know about the
Trump administration.
Where I don't think we have
had the right conversation,
I think this answer's
your question, is--
and I've talked
to a lot of people
in the government about
this, and they just
shrug like, what are
you talking about?
We haven't had a
conversation between
the open internet freedom
people and the national security
people.
And those are-- you can't
be promoting, in my opinion,
openness abroad, and you
can't be promoting freedom
on the net, if you are,
in effect, undermining
those networks and
exploiting them,
especially if part of the
reason you're doing that
is to achieve political
ends in those countries.
So that is what I see as
the fundamental tension
within the US government,
that the US government doesn't
see at all, because it's
just a gigantic thing.
And they can have these
two different agendas.
And the Snowden revelations
caused that hypocrisy
to get noticed.
But it didn't cause
it to change at all.
And that's where the
conversation needs to be had,
and that's a very hard
conversation to have.
And it hasn't happened yet.
That's the point that we need
to figure out our priorities,
I think.
Does that makes sense?
AUDIENCE: Sure.
AUDIENCE: Given what you
said about the increased
domestic surveillance
since 9/11, and even
the recent Department Justice
subpoena of Facebook activists'
user information,
do you think we're
trending towards greater
authoritarian control
on the part of
the US government?
JACK GOLDSMITH: I wouldn't
call it authoritarian
control because it's all
democratically sanctioned
in some extent.
And it's governed
by the rule of law.
We could have a
debate about that.
But I firmly believe it's
governed by the rule of law.
But, yes, we have
increasing, I would
say, national security
control of our networks
since 9/11 through
a variety of means.
And there's no doubt about that.
There's no doubt about that.
And I don't see that
turning back any time.
And, in fact, here's
another prediction
I don't really want to
defend, but I'll just make it.
I think that the
cybersecurity imperative is--
I'm not saying this
is a good idea.
But I think the
cybersecurity imperative
is going to lead the
government to be more
involved in domestic networks.
So I think that the combination
of the 9/11 anti-terrorism
imperative and the
cybersecurity imperative,
that those two things--
I wouldn't call it
authoritarian because I
think it will happen
pursuant to the rule of law.
But it's definitely not
pro-civil liberties.
And I do think that trend will
continue, and I don't see it--
the 702 is up for
re-authorization,
and there might be some
narrowing of it a little bit.
But fundamentally I think that
program will stay in place.
And I really do think that
the cybersecurity problems are
going to require, I don't know
how and I don't know when,
but the government to be much
more involved in networks.
So is that an answer
to your question?
I think it is.
AUDIENCE: What do you mean by,
quote, "European governments
have had more success
than the US government
when it comes imposing back
doors to private companies?"
Do you have examples in mind?
JACK GOLDSMITH: I do.
I don't have the
legislation before me,
and I didn't quite say that.
I was careful about what I said.
I said that they're
further along
in accepting the idea that
we're going to have to have
compromises on encryption.
There've been legislation
proposed and, in some cases,
been passed.
I'm happy if the
person wants to email
me to send them the data
and decent papers on it.
I don't have the details
on the tip of my tongue.
But they're much
further along on that.
And they seem to be more
willing to accept that,
especially for
anti-terrorism reasons.
And the prediction is that if
that comes to fruition, then
it's going to put pressure on
similar measures in the United
States.
AUDIENCE: So I'm British.
And I agree with
what you're saying
about the US has
far more rule of law
in the way it handles things.
But in this space there's
some interesting things
been going on in the
last few decades that
become more and more obvious.
And I'm curious what your view
is about secret law, things
like the interpretations of
the law made by certain, say,
Department of Justice
internal lawyers
or what goes on in
the FISA courts,
those sorts of settings,
where the law is made
and interpretations of
the law are being applied,
but they're not
publicly accessible,
which is unusual for the US.
I'm curious how to take that.
JACK GOLDSMITH: Yeah.
So you probably don't
know this, but not
only do I have views about
it, I've done it myself.
I've been a Justice
Department official
who interpreted law in
secret in some very highly
classified contexts.
I didn't like it then, and I
don't think it's a great thing.
I've written papers
about this, and I'd
be happy to send them to you.
But, in general, I think
that sometimes there
is a need for secret
legal interpretation, when
exposing the legal
interpretation
wouldn't make a public
legal interpretation,
but reveal programs
whose revelation
would be damaging
to those programs
and which are important to the
national security of the United
States.
So I think it's an
inevitable practice.
I think it's over broad.
I think that a lot more legal
interpretation that takes place
in secret can be disclosed.
And I think it
should be disclosed
and has been disclosed.
One of the many virtues
of the Snowden revelations
is that the Director of National
Intelligence, the National
Security Agency, and all the
national security departments
and agencies have been much more
robust, not perfectly, but much
more robust than disclosing
much more so, thousands
and thousands of pages of
documents of FISA court
decisions and legal
interpretations
that that formerly they
never would have disclosed.
And I think that there's--
I think there should be more
of that to the extent possible.
But let me say also,
this can also be--
this is going to maybe
seem paradoxical--
there can and should
be more transparency
inside the government.
So one practice
that I found strange
when I was in the
government, and I've
written about since I've
been of the government, is--
so there is actually
a separation
of powers that takes
place in secret
in national security
inside the government.
And it's a deformed form of
the one we usually think of,
but it's a lot better than
nothing, and it's a substitute.
There's the executive branch,
which interprets the law
and enforces it.
A lot of the time it is reviewed
by the secret court, the FISA
court.
And that is not a
rubber-stamp court.
And there is reporting to the
Congressional intelligence
committees.
It ebbs and flows, but
they have much more,
in my opinion, a
more robust role.
Senator Wyden has been extremely
consequential in holding
the executive branch's
feet to the fire.
And other members of that
committee have as well.
So one thing that--
here's the thing about
secret legal interpretation.
As I say, I did it myself.
When you're in those
secret rooms making
those interpretations,
it would lead
to much better and more
rigorous and narrower
legal interpretations if
all of those interpretations
were being shown to
other institutions.
We weren't in the business
of showing them generally
to the congressional
intelligence committees.
I think that should happen.
It does happen more.
That very act of disclosure
in secret to another body
really has a disciplining
effect on the United States
and takes away the
inevitable-- it diminishes
the harm of the
inevitable compromise
that I think is
necessary for secret law.
So that's what I'd say.
I would say that the
problem is a serious one,
but it's improved
since and because
of the Snowden revelations,
one of many things
that Snowden did.
I believe he caused great
harm to the national security,
but he also achieved
many great benefits.
AUDIENCE: What is the connection
between openness, defined
as free speech and information,
and information security?
You repeatedly say that
openness weakens security.
How will censorship of speech on
the internet improve security?
JACK GOLDSMITH: I didn't
say that censorship
would improve security.
And I'm not sure that follows.
So the example I had in
mind is that the kind
of information operation
that the Russians did,
that's a much more successful
operation in an open society
where the press is not
controlled, where people can
speak and say what they want.
And it's easier to sow
division in a world in which
the government is not
controlling speech and not
controlling the press than it
is in one in which they are.
That's one example
I had in mind.
AUDIENCE: During
the past decades,
there have been incidents
where the authoritarian--
JACK GOLDSMITH: Which case?
AUDIENCE: There have
been some cases where
the authoritarian
countries, their internet
control makes a spill
out of their border
and affecting other countries'
users of their use of internet.
So my question would be
that, did US government
consider cooperating
with other countries
or maybe authoritative agencies
of the cyberspace to push back
these kind of controls?
JACK GOLDSMITH: Can
you give me an example?
AUDIENCE: For example,
I think it was maybe
five or six years ago when
the Chinese government used
the great firewall to block the
"New York Times" and Wikipedia.
JACK GOLDSMITH: Yeah,
they still do, I think.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, of course,
but one particular method
was to pollute the DNS server.
JACK GOLDSMITH: Oh, I see.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
And there had been incidents
where the global DNS server got
polluted instead of--
JACK GOLDSMITH:
So in other words
filtering "The York Times" and
Wikipedia, the Chinese border,
because of the
techniques they used,
caused the services to be
denigrated outside of China?
AUDIENCE: Yes.
JACK GOLDSMITH:
Yes, this happened.
This is another example
of exporting control
I could have added to my list.
So what is the question?
What can the United
States do about it?
AUDIENCE: Did the
United States consider
like cooperating
with other countries
or authoritative agencies of
the cyberspace to pressure,
let's say, China's government
to scale back such behaviors,
I guess?
JACK GOLDSMITH: So I don't know.
There are no authoritative
cybersecurity agencies.
And that's part of the problem.
But I don't know about
that particular case
what the United States did.
But who is it going
to cooperate with?
And what is it going to do?
What are its options?
If the problem is bad enough,
if the extraterritorial effect
of what China is doing at
its borders is bad enough,
then we have a whole--
it's just like any other
international dispute,
where China does
something that has
an adverse effect
in the United States
and that we do the same thing.
There's a whole range of
tools from calling someone
and yelling at them
and threatening them
to imposing sanctions
through retaliating in cyber
or retaliating outside of cyber.
There are a whole host
of tools that we have.
And we've got
extraordinary cyber weapons
that we could use.
But the question is, was that
really a big enough deal?
Did it last long?
Was it on purpose?
Did it go away?
And is the United
States really going
to use its tools to try to
fight back against China?
It's a very tricky proposition.
I imagine what happened,
what usually happens is--
but I don't know
about this case.
I mean, I heard about it, but
I don't know how it went away--
is there were some
diplomatic exchange.
And the United States
probably made clear
that it wasn't pleased
with what China was doing,
and I think it doesn't
happen anymore.
But the real truth is
there's not much we can do.
What can the United States do
if it tells Google to take down
data from its searches globally
to protect Europeans privacy
and that means that you can't
find some information that you
might want to get?
What can the United States do?
It's really Google's
decision, and Google
wants to keep doing
business, as we've
seen, with its compliance with
the right to be forgotten.
It wants to keep doing
business in Europe
because it makes a
lot of money there.
And so there's not a lot
that United States can do.
If the problem rose to a level
where they were taking down
sites for a long period of
time in the United States,
it would elevate.
But it would probably be
resolved diplomatically.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
Actually, one more question.
So, again, the example
would be China.
But the Chinese government
used the security laws--
I mean, I wouldn't
call it an excuse,
but they used security laws
to impose their control
over the internet.
JACK GOLDSMITH: Yes, I know.
Correct.
AUDIENCE: Yeah,
and you mentioned
that for the US
government, it needs
to improve the domestic internet
security as well, right?
So do you predict
that this method will
take a authoritarian twist?
JACK GOLDSMITH: Which method?
AUDIENCE: Like use law
to promote security,
internet security.
JACK GOLDSMITH: In
the United States?
AUDIENCE: Yes.
JACK GOLDSMITH:
Yes, I mean, this
is what I predicted
15 minutes ago.
Maybe I wasn't clear.
I do think--
I don't know along
what dimension,
and I don't know
how it'll happen.
But I do think that the
imperative-- you're talking
about anti-terrorism measures
that China uses as an excuse
to surveil and control the
network more aggressively.
AUDIENCE: Yes.
JACK GOLDSMITH: Yeah, in the
United States, we did that,
too.
After 9/11, the
reaction to 9/11 was
to do more domestic collection.
And so that's what
states do when
they face a threat that
they don't understand,
they can't control, and
they're trying to understand,
and they want to get
more information.
So I think that that does
happen to some degree here,
not nearly to the degree
as in China, obviously.
And I also think
that, as I said,
that the imperative
to do something
to make our networks more
secure will, in some way,
lead the government to be more
involved in those networks.
That's a pretty
vague prediction.
And I'm confident at
that level of abstraction
but not any more
concretely than that.
SPEAKER 1: Thank you very much.
JACK GOLDSMITH:
Thank you very much.
I appreciate it.
Thanks for your good questions.
SPEAKER 1: Thank
you for joining us.
[APPLAUSE]